>> Sean: IT ISN'T JUST
REPUBLICANS COMING AFTER JOE
BIDEN'S STUDENT DEBT FORGIVENESS
TODAY IT WAS ANNOUNCED FORMER
OBAMA SAID IT POURS THE GAS ON
THE INFLATION ISSUE.
YESTERDAY PAUL BAGALA WAS EVEN
MORE WEATHERING IN HIS
CRITICISM.
>> FOR THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU
COULD FUND FREE PRE K FOR EVERY
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD FOR TEN
YEARS.
YOU WOULD DO FOR MORE PEOPLE AND
THE UNDERPRIVILEGED BY DOING PRE
K.
YOU CAN FORGIVE ALL MEDICAL DEBT
WHICH UNLIKE STUDENT DEBT IS NOT
FREELY ENTERED INTO.
SO DEMOCRATS, I'M A PROGRESSIVE,
I WANT TO HELP FOLKS, BUT I
THINK THIS IS TERRIBLE POLICY.
SO WHAT IS MY PARTY DOING WITH
THIS?
THEY'RE DISADVANTAGING, I THINK
THEY'RE NOT HELPING THE PEOPLE
WE'RE HERE TO HELP, WHICH IS
POOR PEOPLE AND UNDERPRIVILEGED
COMMUNITIES, AND THEY'RE NOT
HELPING THEIR POLITICIANS WHO
ARE RUNNING.
>> Sean: YIKES.
I AGREE WITH PAUL BEGALA, SMART
RIGHT ON.
HERE NOW FORMER SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION UNDER DONALD TRUMP
BETSY DeVOS.
SO BETSY WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON
THIS LEAN FORGIVENESS PLAN.
WHAT IMPACT WILL IT HAVE PER
YOUR TIME AND EXPERTISE ON
EDUCATION.
>> WELL, SEAN, FIRST OF ALL,
IT'S A HUNDRED PERCENT ILLEGAL.
>> Sean: RIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS NO
AUTHORITY TO JUST WAVE A MAGIC
WAND AND SUDDENLY FORGIVE
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
CONGRESS HAS THE POWER OF THE
PURSE, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
SECONDLY, IT IS TOTALLY UNFAIR
TO ALL OF THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
TAKEN OUT STUDENT LOANS.
TWO OUT OF THREE AMERICANS WHO
HAVE NOT ATTENDED A FOUR-YEAR
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY.
AND FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
FAITHFULLY HAVE BEEN PAYING
THEIR STUDENT LOANS DOWN, HOW
DOES THAT WORK FOR THEM?
NOT TO MENTION THE VETERANS WHO
HAVE EARNED THEIR TUITION AND
EARNED THE PRIVILEGE OF
ATTENDING HIGHER EDUCATION
BECAUSE OF THEIR SERVICE.
IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR.
IT IS WRONG.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, BUT IT
DOESN'T SOLVE ANY PROBLEM.
ALL IT DOES IS MEAN A POLITICAL
PAYOFF TO VOTERS THAT BIDEN AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION HOPE TO
ATTRACT IN NOVEMBER.
>> Sean: BETSY, IT'S A PAYOFF TO
THE TEACHERS COLLEGES AND TO
UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE
INDOCTRINATING OUR KIDS TURNING
THEM INTO ACTIVISTS, LITTLE
DEMOCRAT VOTERS.
SO WHY WOULDN'T THE DEMOCRATS
SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'RE GOING TO FORGIVE DEBT SO
UNIVERSITIES CAN CHARGE OUR KIDS
EVEN MORE MONEY AND THEY CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY.
>> WELL, AND THERE'S, THERE'S
THE THING, THAT, YOU KNOW, SINCE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TOOK OVER
ALL OF STUDENT LENDING, THE COST
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION HAVE
CONTINUED TO SKY ROCKET.
MULTIPLE TIMES THE RATE OF
INFLATION.
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND THERE IS NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE'S NO GOVERNOR ON THAT FOR
HIGHER INSTITUTIONS.
THEY CAN JUST CONTINUE TO CHARGE
MORE AND MORE.
THEY HAVE NOTHING ON THE HOOK.
THEY'RE GETTING THE MONEY
WHETHER THE STUDENT IS
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT, WHETHER THE
STUDENT PAYS BACK HIS OR HER
LOANS OR NOT.
AND SO IT'S A SYSTEM THAT WAS
BUILT ON A FAILING FOUNDATION TO
BEGIN WITH.
SO THE SOLUTION IS NOT TO JUST
FORGIVE A BUNCH OF DEBT, IT'S TO
REALLY GO LOOK AT THE PROBLEM
AND GET TO THE ROOT OF IT AND
CHANGE THINGS.
>> Sean: BETSY, THE ISSUE I
THINK IS, IF YOU MAKE THE
UNIVERSITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEBT THAT KIDS CAN'T PAY BACK,